libéré bonsoir en précisant et hier
qu'il avait bien l'intention de signer
le décret portant statut des maîtres
directeur d'école le premier ministre
jacques chirac a provoqué aujourd'hui la
riposte des instituteurs c'est une très
bonne réforme disait monsieur chirac
il s'agit de créer un statut pour les
directeurs d'école et de leur conférer
un grade spécifique de les aligner ainsi
sur les statuts des chefs
d'établissements du secondaire lorraine
cusin et jean-françois chevet ont
recueilli les témoignages d'instituteurs
et de parents d'élèves dans une école
primaire du 20e arrondissement à paris
l'école primaire du boulevard de
belleville à paris une grosse école de
310 enfants
mardi dernier sur les treize instituteur
11 étaient en grève contre le projet de
décret dans cette école où les enfants
appartiennent à de nombreuses
communautés en travaille beaucoup en
équipe pédagogique et on réagit mal à la
décision du premier ministre de signer
le texte
nous pensons pas non cela va diviser
leur rapport de travail au sein des
établissements et je pense sincèrement
que l'ensemble des collègues
et d'accord pour refuser ce décret c'est
une atteinte à la liberté du maître dans
sa classe le fait que le directeur
puisse imposer ses idées pédagogique au
bout de vingt ans de carrière je pense
que j'ai rencontré différents directeurs
et différentes directrice c'est que
majoritairement ce sont des gens qui ont
su asseoir leur autorité et qui ont su
exercer leurs responsabilités
pour l'instant les enseignants sont
encore partagés sur les moyens de lutter
contre le texte
effectivement les prêts
c'est le problème là les gars de paroles
qui sont réellement ennuyer lorsque les
enseignants font grève n'est pas
accueillir les enfants mes collègues
sont très motivés pour mener une action
dure jusqu'au retrait de ce décret
qu'est ce que c'est une action dure mais
une action dure ça vous prendre toutes
les formes depuis une la grève
reconductible jusqu'à d'aider les
positions de grève administrative de
grève du zèle et c'est enfin un truc de
différentes actions sont envisagées
quant aux parents même ceux qui sont
hostiles au décret il envisage mal
un mouvement de grève qui s'étendrait
qui les désaccords et tous les
traitements possibles parce qu'ils ont
fait affiché les forces anti cheat monde
et fichez moi je ne conteste pas leur
droit de grève c'est le droit de grève
il existe est sûre ça manquait qu'ils
s'amendent est pour certaines choses des
perturbations sont donc prévisibles dans
les écoles à partir de lundi mais selon
des modalités qui seront définies
localement